Drone footage shown on President
zielinski's social media channel
revealed the extent of the damage to the
gohofka power plant the blast smashed
through the dam wall resulting in this
massive breach water from the danipro
river is now gushing Downstream in the
direction of the southern city of her
son raising fears of massive flooding in
low-lying areas forcing some residents
to evacuate shocked locals woke up to
the destruction zelenski has placed the
blame squarely on Russia's shoulders
while the Kremlin has accused kiv of
blowing it up the dam is in
russian-occupied territory and is
important for the safe running of the
kremlin-controlled zeppar Asia nuclear
power plant which must go back to
authorities say is stable for now